what we bring to the table is is sort of
a different outside the Beltway aunty
conventional wisdom hi I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer raisin TV and here at Tom
Bevan one of the founders of Real Clear
Politics site that launched in 2000 is
one of the leading news aggregators in
policy and politics and includes writers
from across the country not to mention
the globe Tom thanks for being here but
what prompted you to launch
RealClearPolitics back in the late 90s
it was the first time that you could get
up and read what was written in the LA
Times and The New York Times in the same
day all these publications were coming
online and so we thought to ourselves
that was the genesis of the idea how
about creating a site for people like us
who have a real passion for for politics
and for elections and create a space
where we gathered all the best news
information analysis everything and put
it one place and became sort of a
one-stop shop for political junkies one
of your more popular features is you're
pulling on a lot of different races and
and you've a verge polls to get this
data why do you think that's been so
popular there's so much media out there
now and there's so much more polling out
there now and partisans trying to take
those polls and spin them for their own
benefit on a day to day basis the
averages have really become an
indispensable way of sort of cutting
through all the clutter and looking at
okay right now as we sit here today this
is where the race stands they've had a
great track record for accuracy both at
the presidential level but also in a lot
of the Senate races governor's races
pollsters in the end they want to get it
right - and they're running a business
as are we we are very sort of particular
about you know who's included in the
average and and how those averages are
sort of managed over time because again
you know the numbers are the numbers and
we want that average to be held as sort
of the gold standard across the board
you have conservative voices liberal
voices libertarian voices now do you
think that the Internet provides more of
a more content for people to have more
discussion based conversations or you
know a lot of critics say that it sort
of just reinforces people's own beliefs
and they go to sites where they don't
really have to look any further than
what they subscribe to already now
that's right I mean the Internet is very
polarized and you will go to a site like
National Review for example you can go
there
every day for five years and never see a
liberal opinion and you can go to the
Nation magazine you know every day for
five years and not see a conservative
opinion and so that's one of the things
that we focus very much on and try very
hard to to provide people with a variety
of views across the political spectrum
and also a variety of subject matter I
mean we want it to be a site that sort
of all-encompassing of the issues of the
day as much as there is this sort of you
know echo effect where you have people
sort of reading only their favorite
authors or reading only articles that
reinforce their own viewpoints we do
still hear a lot from folks who who
appreciate seeing two pundits for
example arguing both sides of an issue
they like to read that and that's one of
the things that you know the functions
of the site is I would say it can serve
as sort of a cheat sheet you can spend
five minutes there looking just scanning
the headlines scanning the latest polls
to see you know what's being written out
there in a day or you can spend five
hours digging through and actually
reading the internals of all the polls
are reading through all these different
arguments and so I think people like the
way the site functions that way real
clear has really expanded to other areas
outside of politics you know you have
real clear religion real clear books
real clear world what kinds of things
you have to think about for your
branding expansion and how do you
measure your success the idea really was
based on the success of the politics
site and the model that we have was to
expand to different these different
industries I mean there's really nothing
no industry that we can't expand our
model to and really all the sites have
been doing great because it's based on
sort of the the model if you like what
we do at Real Clear Politics you'll love
you know you'll love what we do for all
of these different we call them
verticals brand extensions and and
they've they've been doing very well you
also generate a lot of information
written specifically for real clear
sites it's not just a news aggregation
anymore do you think I mean because
people saw that you were sort of a
trustworthy source for directing people
to different news sites that's allowed
them to trust you more in terms of your
individual content and we're still a
very small operation relative to our
competitors and we're competing against
obviously the Washington Post The New
York Times people who have you know 10
20 50 100 times more resources than we
do so we approach that in a very
we're not going to compete against the
Washington Post or the wire services for
example to break news stories
necessarily what we bring to the table
is is sort of a different outside the
Beltway anti conventional wisdom look at
whether it's you know whether it's an
issue or whether it's the race itself I
mean that's where we can really add
value for our readers do you think it's
still sites like The Washington Post in
the New York Times that are breaking
news or is it coming from
new media and blogs it's coming from all
over the place I mean yeah it's
certainly coming from blogs it's coming
from from other sites obviously like
Politico one of the challenges that
we're facing and that other folks are
facing is that the way people are
consuming information certainly the
younger generation I mean for example
the number of visits to local air
politics via mobile or via tablet is up
you know by 20 fold over the last couple
of years and that's something that you
know people aren't just coming to
sitting down at their computers and
dialing up the website right they are
they're getting it on their phones
they're getting it on their iPads and
and that's a challenge for us you know
not only from a content production
standpoint and transferring what we do
what we have always done our business
into this new you know these new
platforms but also sort of as a business
proposition from an advertising
standpoint Tom thanks so much for
talking to us crazy TV and Tracy
Oppenheimer
you